الانسان هذا هو الواقع الان باحثون في
الصين وجدوا وزير الاسره الاسلام في
المختبر باستخدام خلايا جذعيه تضلل
تقاريرهم لنرى كيف يعمل الامر الاستاذ
مصنوعه من اسنان الفك السفلي للطيران
والبول البشريه نسبه نجاح جيده جدا كبدايه
وهي تقدر بثلاثين في المائه المشروع لا
يزال في بدايه الطريق الاسباب المصنعه
ليست سوى صلابه اثناء الانسان في الوقت
الراهن وقد يرجع السبب الى سرعه من البور
على اي حال هذه الاخبار الكبيره تاتي بعد
يوم من علمنا بان مدرس جامعي هولنديا
سيطبق خطيره لحم المصنوعه من لحم بقر
مستقره انها لن تبدو كما تظهر في الصوره
وفي الواقع انها ليست مصنوعه من لحم البقر
انها مصنوعه من الخلايا الجدعيه موسكو
كثيره في 5 اغسطس